bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui refait la
semaine politique et parlementaire avec
à mes côtés kathia gilder bonjour katia
bonjour oriane et c'est une semaine
chargée sur le front social
manifestation des policiers grève dans
les transports et la mobilisation dans
la rue qui se poursuit contre la loi
travail
deux manifestations ont eu lieu cette
semaine une mobilisation nationale est
annoncé à paris le 14 juin et l'état
d'urgence a donc été prolongée pour deux
mois après les sénateurs les députés ou
donné le feu vert se maintient l'état
d'urgence sera donc en vigueur pendant
l'euro de football qui commence le 10
juin prochain en france
premier sujet de friction dans la
primaire à droite le vote des français
de l'étranger bureau politique tendue
mardi au siège des républicains un
compromis a finalement été trouvé entre
vote papier et vote électronique
mais la compétition entre les candidats
c'est qu'ils leur vie ted parlement
hebdo cette semaine et david douillet
bonjour vous êtes député les
républicains des yvelines vice-président
la région ile-de-france président de la
fédération l'appui qu'un des yvelines et
vous êtes chargé aux conseillers à la
région ile-de-france de l'action
internationale et du tourisme va en
parler tout à l'heure mais d'abord place
à l'actualité politique
et on commence par lundi il y en a qui y
va arnaud montebourg de retour en
politique c'est la question
pour arnaud montebourg et ses soutiens
l'ascension du mont beuvray avait comme
un air de campagne
et pourtant à l'arrivée pas de
déclaration de candidature mais plutôt
un appel lancé aux français je vous
propose de bâtir dans les mois qui
viennent un grand projet alternatif pour
le pays
ce projet pour la france venez le faire
avec nous et faisons le ensemble il sera
bien temps ensuite s'il a la consistance
que j'espère il sera bien temps de se
décider sur les candidatures l'ancien
ministre en a profité pour réaffirmer sa
vision de la gauche dans une anna fort
comme pour mieux viser françois hollande
être de gauche être de gauche c'est
considérer que le pouvoir politique doit
être parfois supérieures au pouvoir
économique
être de gauche c'est aimer invention du
futur être de gauche c'est aimer et
chérir sa patrie c'est romain gary et le
pape françois et à tous ceux qui voient
cette accélération comme une concurrence
au mouvement d' emmanuel macron arnaud
montebourg fait comme si de rien n'était
il cherche pas de différence de
similitudes a aucune importance
alors comment trouver un espace
politique entre françois hollande et
jean luc mélenchon en passant par une
primaire de toute la gauche
il serait souhaitable que cette
confrontation d'idées qui est saine qui
est juste et nécessaire elle ait lieu
dans une primaire de toute la gauche
compte nous on va continuer de la
demande et la primaire toute la gauche
arnaud montebourg se donne jusqu'à l'été
pour construire ce projet participatif
avant peut-être une véritable
déclaration de candidature david
douillet est ce que vous prenez au
sérieux le projet montebourg si je puis
dire ce qui peut être un candidat
sérieux pour vous la droite des
républicains
d'abord ça va être un candidat sérieux
pour françois hollande par je crois que
là on a on a une petite accumulation
autre côté on ne peut mieux que les
autres pour les premières de la droite
elle en train de se faire à gauche
vivant entre
je m'accroche une bourre et puis tous
les autres qui arriveront par la suite
le président lui-même qui de par ce
qu'il dit parce qu'il fait je trouve à
titre personnel il est déjà en campagne
bon est-ce que l'atv voix montebourde
emmanuel macron c'est l'illustration de
la difficulté de françois hollande à
s'imposer comme candidat légitime bah
déjà la difficulté du président c'est
d'être président voilà c'est sa grande
difficulté depuis le début de son
quinquennat il a été un bon candidat
il a gagné il a jamais été président
c'est ça la vérité on s'en est rendu
compte à l'assemblée je pense que mes
collègues sénateurs diront peut-être la
même chose mais en tout état de cause
les français l'ont compris et le font
ressentir à travers les les sondages
d'impopularité qu'il qu'il bénéficie
aujourd'hui bon sa politique elle est
clairement un désastre absolu et ce
matin encore à la radio j'entendais des
salariés qui explique encore et qui
encore 7,7 conséquences quotidiennes de
la suppression des heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées
voilà les gens n'ont pas oublié ils le
vivent au quotidien
c'est 200 ou 300 euros important pour
des millions de familles françaises
ils ne les ont plus cette surtaxation
taxation des ménages des entreprises
dans notre pays qui a eu lieu dès 2015
après l'allègement mais c'est un coup de
dupes on taxe beaucoup au début on en
retire un peu à la fin pour avoir une
petite attitude électoralistes voilà
déjà c'est pas du bien à gauche qui dit
parler franchement qui met un peu les
pieds dans une classe et emmanuel macron
vous vous en pensez quoi
c'est une blague c'est une blague blague
c'est une blague
moi je sais ta vie de jean pierre
chevènement par exemple nous avait dit
chose de très juste je trouve ou lorsque
si on reste ministre on ferme sa gueule
sinon quitte le gouvernement
ballack aujourd'hui je ne comprends pas
enfin je pas le seul on discute souvent
et que ce soit à gauche comme à droite
beaucoup de citoyens comme moi ne
comprennent pas comment on peut créer un
jour
un parti qui n'est ni de droite ou de
gauche et en même temps rester dans un
gouvernement de gauche et ne pas être
d'accord avec son premier ministre sur
bien des sujets le dernier en date les
salaires des patrons des grands patrons
il est au salaire est désavoué en
permanence se désabonner en permanence
les ados dont la cacophonie qu'est-ce
que vous ne confère le mental est là
elle existe qui ne qui ne démissionne
pas ou que françois hollande et manuel
valls ne fasse pas preuve de plus
d'autorité les deux les deux les deux
voilà il n'y a pas de cohérence il n'y a
pas de logique
alors tout le monde vocifère les uns
contre les autres en catimini ou
publiquement de temps en temps mon lourd
en est l'exemple absolu ben si les
partis du gouvernement
au moins il a le courage filippetti
aussi par exemple bon bah toi aussi
voilà donc tout coule déjà depuis
longtemps de leur part mais c'est bien
au moins une zone ils ont ils ont une
colonne vertébrale ce qui est pas le cas
des personnages que vous m'avez site
étant premier ministre qu'est le musée
l'économie la cc c'est pas bien et la
cacophonie elle se ressent je dirais
c'est comme c'est comme la lfh image en
montagne ça fond ça coule dans les
vallées voilà aujourd'hui ça coule dans
les rues la cacophonie à victoria a
compris le message en reparler on va y
revenir david douillet on va passer au
mardi journée qui a débuté par une
interview matinale du président de la
république françois hollande invité de
la matinale d'europe 1 le chef de l'état
a redit sa détermination à faire passer
la loi travail mais il a aussi endossé
ses habits de campagne ne se privant pas
d' attaques contre la droite
tous les français quelles que soient
leurs revenus payent des impôts de
consommation et quand je vois que
certains candidats aux primaires de la
droite veulent augmenter la tva je dis
ce n'est pas juste parce que ça va
toucher tous les français indifféremment
il est entré en campagne françois
hollande plus contredit il a expliqué
aussi qu'il aurait pas dû toucher la tva
sociale que sarkozy avait mis en place
voilà donc c'est des contradictions
permanentes bien sûr qu'il en campagne
évidemment qu'il en campagne il en
campagne depuis bien longtemps et il est
doux et voilà il est doué il est doué ce
qui s'est passé hier soir on est
un exemple caricatural l'explosion du
groupe écologiste à l'assemblée excusez
moi mais je dois vous chamboulé vaut
jouer parce que tout ça est et est une
stratégie qui est très bien mené qui est
finement menée et qui aboutit à des
choses comme celles ci justement parce
qu'il ya quand même une colère sociale
très forte une contestation politique et
finalement y tiens tiens très forte
attention mais pas tomber dans le
panneau
non mais en tout cas il est quand même
attaqué de toute part rarement un
président va lui qui a été attaqué deux
de telle manière vous les reconnaissez
les élèves de la tenir le choc mais les
tenir le choc de quoi il est au chaud à
10 est ce facile par contre d'être en
totale contradiction avec ce qu'il n'a
jamais dit ou ce qu'il ne dit pas où ce
qui la mange ce qu'il n'a qu'il a menti
il a menti à tous ceux qui nous ont fait
confiance quand ils l'ont fait à ma
famille est donc non seulement ça va pas
mieux mais ça s'empire
voilà la loi une connerie elle est loin
elle est là si des gens de gauche et
surtout malheureusement et je pas des
casseurs d'extrême gauche viennent fiche
la pagaille dans nos rues et aujourd'hui
ça on n'en parle pas suffisamment dans
l'immédiat mais occasionne par rapport à
des grèves qui sont mises mise en place
à une pénurie d'essence dans tout le
pays sauf en ile-de-france pour ça qu'on
n'a pas le passé mais dans tout l'ouest
du pays on touille on est en train
depuis avoir d'essence
on aime le pôle il est payé en train de
se bloquer depuis depuis hier c'est bel
et bien parce qu'il a menti à tout le
monde
il a voulu faire plaisir à tout le monde
et à personne et puis voilà et une
politique c'est comme si rouler à 200 km
heure sur l'autoroute avec les yeux
bandés abandonné bas on s'expose
et là il est en train d'exploser et
c'est la france qui ont subi les
conséquences
alors on va passer à l'actualité de
votre parti qui a réuni son bureau
politique
mardi il était question la primaire à
droite est de savoir notamment comment
les français de l'étranger
allez voter pour cette élection ambiance
tendue et compétition au menu comme nous
le raconte quentin calmait
une heure de réunion pour éteindre la
première polémique de cette primaire
finalement le compromis entre le vote
papier et le vote électronique des
français de l'étranger a été adopté à
l'unanimité dans les plus grandes villes
du monde qui concentre le plus de
français on va travailler à
l'installation de bureaux de vote
physique pour ça il faudra bien sûr que
ce soit possible sur un plan de
l'organisation que ce soit légal que les
pays le valide dans le reste des
endroits ça sera à votre internet on a
arrêté la date du 15 juillet donc le 15
juillet prochain tous les français qui
vivent à l'étranger seront où il vote la
fin de deux semaines de débats au sein
du parti
certains accusant nicolas sarkozy
d'avoir voulu restreindre le nombre de
votants à l'élection interne
d'autres faisant valoir l'équité entre
les électeurs au début c'était papier
pour tout le monde on trouve un accord
partagé entre papier scrutin
électronique
tu as ni coup de force ni opérations de
re de frein de qui que ce soit ne pas
changer les règles tout temps c'est pas
la première modification il faut
vraiment que ce soit la dernière
et c'est bien la haute autorité qui a la
main sur l'organisation des primaires
c'est pas le bureau politique
un bureau politique ou le ton serait
monté entre nicolas sarkozy et alain
juppé et la fin d'une première zone de
turbulences sur ce scrutin
encore inédit à droite david douillet
vous étiez à ce bureau politique est ce
que c'est vrai que le ton est monté
donc elle intervient non alors j'ai une
notion du ton qui monte pas c'est pas
normal alors non ça pas du tout monté un
bureau politique ça sert à quoi
justement à se rassembler pour discuter
des choses qui vont qui vont pas se
projeter dans l'avenir
c'est l'avis du parti bon voilà une
primaire elle est organisée
elle est organisée par thierry solère il
le fait bien
c'est pas simple il ya des candidats de
poids étant mieux avec de grosses
qualités pour les uns et les autres en
train de faire plaisir des zones
d'incertitude la zone d'incertitude
c'est télé france et l'étranger
je la connais parfaitement j'ai été
secrétaire d'état le premier secrétaire
d'état des français de l'étranger
j'ai commencé à mettre en place et voir
consiel l'a fait après quand je suis
parti aux sports le vote de la
présidentielle pour les français de
l'étranger
non seulement le vote pour les
présidentielles et les députés qui est
totalement différent qui a été à cette
époque totalement différent entre un
vote classique papier pour le président
et un vote avec quatre systèmes
différents le vote électronique
la procuration le vote classique et
ensuite le vot bon peu importe donc je
connais parfaitement la difficulté on
parle de quoi on parle de personnes qui
sont 70% des votants sont un support à
sont les grandes villes dans lesquelles
on peut mettre des bureaux de vote sans
aucun problème voilà non pas de 30 % de
personnes qui sont à l'écart très à
l'écart dans des contrées quelquefois
compliqué dangereux mais c'est pas un
problème mais sur ce sujet est-ce que
l'ambiance était tendue avec une passe
d'armes entre nicolas sarkozy alain
juppé bas de tableau entre les deux pour
moi non voilà pour moi non le problème
n'en était pas un le problème a été mis
en exergue
parce qu'au départ on ne parlait que du
vote papier tout le monde était rongé
là-dessus personnes avaient probablement
et d'un seul coup le vote électronique
on ne sait comment s'est immiscé dans
cette affaire-là donc il a fallu le
régler on va en parler on va revenir
plus longuement sur cette primaire de
droite et votre soutien à nicolas
sarkozy à la fin de cette émission dans
l'album du scan mais on va continuer à
dérouler l'actualité parlementaire
puisque mardi nerea belle connerie et
est auditionné devant les sénateurs
devant la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat le projet de loi elle
comme riquet arrivera au sénat le 13
juin et la ministre du travail se dit
déterminée j'aborde le débat au sénat
dans un état d'esprit fait de
détermination et de gravité aussi une
détermination à parler enfin du contenu
du texte
en s'affranchissant si possible de
certaines postures aussi convenu
qu'artificielle et une gravité apporter
un texte qui je crois est juste et
nécessaire pour notre pays
david douillet à la majorité sénatoriale
qui souhaitent revenir au texte initial
est ce que vous comptez sur le sénat
pour qui le gouvernement n'a pas du tout
sûr je me mets à genoux devant eux
ole opry qu'il le fasse bien sûr qu'ils
nous renvoient un texte à nouveau
remplie rempli de bonnes chances de
bonnes choses qui vont nous faire
dégager de l'immobilisme qui existe dans
ce pays pour entreprendre pour créer de
la richesse
comment ils passent audition sur
audition
le monte au créneau profitable alors
pourquoi je donne aussi
oui c'est courageux mais un chemin de
croix avec une croix que qu'on lui a mis
sur les épaules que françois hollande
lui a mis sur les épaules est élu il a
lui fait supporter cette croix qui est
énorme parce que parce qu'il en est le
responsable
il a il a manipulé en corse de ceux qui
ont voté pour lui tous ceux qui ont cru
en lui ceux qui sont dans l'hémicycle là
c'est c'est du jamais vu pour un
gouvernement à deux personnes deux
députés près il y avait une motion de
rejet qui était votée qui était présenté
et 1 et par la gauche
c'est du jamais vu mais il ya eu encore
une deuxième lecture les choses peuvent
éventuellement si les choses vont
tellement se passer et puis on veut on
alarme absolu qu'est le 49-3 qui va nous
tomber dessus alors vous pensez qu'elle
s'est fait déjà que de toute façon le
gouvernement l'utilisera modèles fins
oui je pense je pense qu'on va voir le
travail des députés on va de quelle
manière ils vont m'aimer pas quant à la
qualité leurs travaux mais de quelle
manière ça ils sont orientés mais je
pense qu'on y arrivera en attendant la
mobilisation se poursuit dans la rue 128
personnes ont encore manifesté hier des
manifestations sont annoncées notamment
le temps le soir font sur les soixante
résidents sont 10 millions alors un déjà
c'est un premier pas mais c'est une
minorité qui fédère vous minimisez la
continent je ne mise pas mais je
comprends les gens qui sont déçus je
comprends franchement jeu on n'a pas les
mêmes idées mais je me mets à leur place
je me suis fait avoir mais et c'est cet
essai cette revendication là on entend
en réalité mais sur le fond du texte et
le fond de cette loi on en a besoin mais
en urgence il faut il faudra aller bien
plus loin que ce que même dans la
première version la loi est claire il
faudrait bien plus loin que ce qui est
proposé
mais c'est surtout que ces
manifestations se déroulent dans un
climat tendu avec parfois de la violence
est ce que vous craignez une radicale
parce que le gouvernement excusez moi
mais les policiers depuis depuis la 5ème
république ont dû défiler si je ne me
trompe pas quatre fois c'est la
troisième fois on va venir maintenant
c'est deux fois sous gouvernement
hollande ou en octobre 2015 pour
conséquence est contestée madame taubira
et là encore cette fois-ci cela deux
fois sous gouvernement hollande on parle
de la sec on verrait celle de la vème
république
vous rendez compte on va venir un sur
cette manifestation des policiers
puisque mercredi d' descendait dans la
rue les policiers qui dénoncent un
manque de reconnaissance disent leur
ras-le-bol de la haine et de la violence
à leur encontre
ils sont donc descendus mercredi dans la
rue mais à paris des casseurs ont
incendié un véhicule de police blessant
ses deux occupants
rim benameur une scène d'une violence
sans précédent
des casseurs ont essayé de mettre le feu
à une voiture de police alors que deux
fonctionnaires sont à l'intérieur
peu après quatre personnes sont
interpellées
une enquête est ouverte pour tentative
d'homicide volontaire
réaction immédiate de manuel valls il
promet d'autres interpellations et des
sanctions implacable il faut agir
interpellé et faire en sorte que la
justice sur la base de preuves qu'ils
soient les plus nette possible puisse
condamner avec la plus grande fermeté et
ces nouvelles violences interviennent en
plein débat sur la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est indigné face à ces
brutalités j'aurais énormément de
difficultés à considérer qu'il ya
derrière ces hordes sauvages
quelque chose qui ressemble à de
l'humanité ou a fortiori à un début
idéal
depuis des semaines à chaque
manifestation
les affrontements entre casseurs et
forces de l'ordre se répète
inadmissible pour la droite qui
dénoncent le laxisme du gouvernement
david douillet dans une position sinon
vous êtes chargé de veiller à l'image de
la france à l'étranger
cette voiture brûlée a fait le tour des
catastrophes au l'immobilisme du
gouvernement
tout ça pour faire plaisir à quelques
jeunes gauchistes et tout ça dans des
attitudes déjà électoraliste de la part
du candidat hollande info quand même
bien de souligner cette affaire-là
bon on ne sécurise pas comme il le
faudrait les manifestations
le résultat une voiture brûlée des
images qui ont fait le tour du monde
je vous le dis c'est plusieurs milliards
ils se sont envolés dans cette voiture
plusieurs milliards de retombées
économiques elle a fait le tour du monde
cette image là on a eu l'année dernière
les les attentats terroristes
donc c'est catastrophique c'est
catastrophique pour l'économie française
parce que qu'est-ce que les caisses
qu'un étranger se dit je vous rappelle
que rien que sur l'île de france les
retombées économiques du tourisme et 21
milliards 30 % moins à cause des
attentats
cette année qu'est ce que cette image va
redonner encore que là c'est nous mêmes
parce que on est on se met dans
l'incapacité on ne veut pas sécurisé on
met pas les moyens pour sécuriser une
manifestation c'est à dire qu'on laisse
faire vous dites qu à une défaillance
grave du système de maintien de l'ordre
et des dates de forme ce matin via
l'autorité de l'état
parce que à la tête de l'état que ce
soit le ministre de l'intérieur comme le
président l'a public
on a donné des consignes laxistes
regardez dans tous les autres
gouvernements on n'a jamais assisté à
des choses comme ça c'est une première
pour quoi posez vous la question mais
sur le fond du problème un au delà des
violences les policiers manifestent
aussi contre une surcharge de travail
contre une baisse des effectifs est ce
que la droite n'a pas une responsabilité
sur ce sujet une responsabilité de
keller parce que nous avons voulu des
effets des led les budgets vous savez c
on a voulu remettre les policiers dans
la rue
le message a été complètement détourné
marketé par une gauche qui est arrivé au
pouvoir aux airs vous avez réduit les
effectifs pas du tout en réalité on a
voulu réorganiser le système policier
pour que des gens qui ne font que de
l'administratif que de l'administration
reviennent à leur métier initial se
quitter en alors ça a été stoppé un par
la gauche ajoie sont tout de suite les
casseurs comment arrêter des questions
est-ce que vous avez une mesure choc
vous pas arrêter
ils sont identifiés regardez dans la
majorité de
d'entre eux regardent tous ceux qui ont
qui ont commis ces méfaits contre cette
voiture était connu des services avaient
déjà été condamnés pour la plupart
d'entre eux étaient interdits de
participer à des manifestations
mais quand on fait une association tout
ça est encadrée on peut contrôler et d
identifier les mois avancent mais bien
sûr il démissionne pas je suis pas mise
de l'intérieur mais si je les paie il ya
une manifestation qui dit qui démarre on
a des policiers en civil qui sont
capables à l'oeil de voir au niveau rien
qu'au niveau vestimentaire pour certains
parce qu'on le sait il ya des capuches
pour ceux masqués et c'était extra de
dire vos papiers etc de contrôler les
gens qui ont déjà été condamnés n'ont
pas le droit de participer à une
manifestation c'est du laxisme à l'état
pur voilà je vous le dis on va passer au
jeudi
david douillet jeudi une pétition sur la
rémunération des patrons dans libération
quarante personnalités responsables
politiques syndicaux ou intellectuels
ont lancé un appel pour demander au
gouvernement de légiférer afin de
limiter le salaire des patrons
elsa mondain gavât le patron du parti
socialiste jean christophe cambadélis
l'économiste thomas piketty la députée
écologiste cécile duflot ou encore le
leader de la cgt philippe martinez tous
ont signé un appel dans le quotidien
libération pour demander au gouvernement
de légiférer pour qu'un patron ne
perçoivent pas plus de 100 smic
depuis quelques semaines les révélations
sur les salaires des grands patrons font
scandale
paul hermelin chez capgemini et sa
rémunération à 4,8 millions d'euros ou
encore celle de carlos ghosn le patron
de renault 7,2 millions d'euros dans ce
cas elle a été décidé contre l'avis de
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires le
premier ministre propose que ce ne soit
plus possible donc il faut donner aux
actionnaires davantage du pouvoir pour
que ce qui saute quand ces rémunérations
puis devant leurs actionnaires
revenir sur ses décisions si c'est
nécessaire le gouvernement a déjà
plafonner la rémunération des dirigeants
d'entreprises dont l'état détient la
majorité du capital pour les entreprises
privées
un code de bonne conduite a été édité
par le patronat mais il apparaît
toujours du ans
fisant des amendements vont donc être
déposé dans le cadre de la loi sapin 2
mais une voix dissonante s'est déjà fait
entendre la personne du ministre de
l'économie je pense que c'est un mauvais
sujet pour la loi je ne pense pas que le
législateur dans un seul pays puisse
dans un monde ouvert
considérer qu'il y à un plafond de
rémunération je pense que ça reste la
décision de l'entreprise le même
emmanuel macron qui avait menacé de
légiférer il y a deux semaines lors des
questions au gouvernement
emmanuel macron ne crois pas qu'on
puisse encadrer les cadeaux avant est ce
que vous avez dit dans votre reportage
où il est dit la mère ce qu'elle joue
avant donc quand vous marquez voilà
c'est un produit marketing
voilà sur le fond est ce que vous
soutenez vous cet appel une fois
légiférer non non c'est 40 signataires
tous de gauche évidemment sont enfin
j'aimerais qu'il se réveille et qu'ils
s'aperçoivent dans quel monde ils vivent
voilà si nous vivions dans un monde
globalisé communistes voient là détenu
par un parti qui régit tout le monde
entier ils peuvent le faire
on peut le faire c'est pas le cas c'est
comme ça donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
tout ce tous nos grands patrons que ce
soit ceux qui créent leur entreprise ou
ceux qui les gèrent après tout ce qu'on
a du talent vont partir
on va plus les avoir les bons et les
bons points logique de l'art les bons
internationale et un marché
mais messieurs c'est comme c'est comme
une équipe de foot
les meilleurs joueurs vont être pris
ailleurs s'il vous plaît si vous
plafonner leurs salaires il ya voilà
sept ils vont partir ils vont être ils
vont être pris par deux entreprises aux
états-unis en australie où vous voulez
et ils ne sont plus chez nous il ne
développe en développant plus de de la
même manière avec toutes les qualités
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui pour développer
nos entreprises françaises ils ne sont
plus là je veux dire quoi en disant ça
mais c'est absurde de de partir se sait
sur ces contrées là d'ailleurs les
conseils d'administration ou les
actionnaires les actionnaires pouvoir
oui j'ai lancé le pouvoir n'est pas
forcément contre n'est pas contraignant
est-ce qu'il faut rendre ses décisions à
ce que j'ai en ce que je
ce que je pense sur ces sujets là c'est
vrai que quelquefois il y a de la
justice il ya une injustice terrible qui
est scandaleuse c'est lorsqu'un grand
patron s'en va dans l'entreprise d'une
entreprise avec un parachute plus que
dorée et lorsqu'il à venir une reprise
en déficit ou dans une situation si
catastrophique ça c'est scandaleux
mais lorsqu'un patron ce quelqu un de
ceux dont on a parlé à capgemini ghosn
ou les autres réussissent remplissent
les carnets de commandes font progresser
l'entreprise développe l'emploi et créer
de la richesse
mais ça me dérange pas qu'ils soient
bien payés ces gens là voilà par contre
une petite répétition un peu plus un peu
plus valorisante pour toute l'entreprise
en général aussi doit aller de pair mais
par contre un patron qui échoue doit
être sanctionné et ne plus ne pas être
dansé dansé niveau de rémunération c'est
hors de question
c'est injuste la méritocratie doit être
appliquée à plein sur ces sujets alors
on va revenir à l'assemblée vous et y
étiez les députés donc vous ont voté
après les sénateurs la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence pour permettre des
mesures exceptionnelles notamment
pendant l'euro de foot qui commence très
bientôt l'état d'urgence est prolongée
de deux mois françois goulard pour 46
contre 20 donc l'article unique tu est
adoptée la troisième prorogation de
l'état d'urgence est officiellement voté
elle instaure deux mois supplémentaires
de mesures exceptionnelles en termes de
lutte contre le terrorisme
le ministre de l'intérieur a évoqué la
gravité de la menace et l'imminence de
l'euro de football pour convaincre les
parlementaires
il ne nous est pas permis de nous croire
à l'abri ni de considérer que le péril
imminent qui a justifié en novembre
dernier la proclamation de l'état
d'urgence a disparu ajoute que dans les
mois qui viennent les enjeux de sécurité
seront particulièrement importants pour
des raisons qui tiennent à
l'organisation de cette grande
manifestation qu'est l'euro 2016 et
d'autres manifestations estivales
la majorité des députés socialistes à
voter pour la provocation avec dans le
texte une modification le retrait des
perquisitions administrative
durant les premières semaines qui ont
suivi le 13 novembre
les perquisitions administratives ont
été nombreuses elles ont permis de
chercher et de trouver les
renseignements nécessaires pour
désorganiser les réseaux terroristes
désormais elle ne bénéficie plus ni de
l'effet de surprise ni de l'utilité
spécifiques qui les justifiait au cours
des six derniers mois
une décision à laquelle s'est opposé le
groupe l'est républicain qui souhaite
également que le gouvernement utilise
avec plus de force
les outils de l'état d'urgence oui nous
vous appelons monsieur le ministre à
faire plus d'interdictions de
rassemblement qui troublent l'ordre
public
oui nous vous appelons à faire plus de
perquisitions administratives pouvant
protéger les français quant au député du
front de gauche
il voit dans ce nouveau vote une dérive
sécuritaire de l'exécutif
est ce que cette prolongation de l'état
d'urgence était nécessaire voire
obligatoire mais est ce que cela va être
efficace surtout aussi si c'est aussi
efficace que pendant les manifestations
on a on a de quoi s'occuper voilà et on
a une grosse préoccupation à voir si on
veut parler des fans zone par exemple
sous la tour eiffel
quand on regarde très précisément les
les objectifs que s'est mit s'est imposé
des ch pour aller toucher notre notre
monde qui est un monde de liberté etc
la tour eiffel figure en première liste
vous rendez compte c'est servir sur un
plateau une occasion de faire un
massacre massif alors de personnes que
les honneurs d'une wild-card de ne pas
interdire ces faits oui dès le départ
est sûr qu'il a tort
et peut-il encore le faire une folie
sans créer un gouvernement peut tout
faire
s'entraîner six si vous ne pouvez pas
faire à deux gouvernements n'a pas lieu
d'être dans un gouvernement sait qu'il
doit le faire c'est urgent de le faire
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas laisser ça
vient c'est trop c'est trop beau tour
eiffel des centaines de milliers de
personnes tous les jours doit interdire
les fans zone en tout cas celles qui
sont aussi symbolique que celle là
ça veut dire quelque part c'est la moire
étincelles dans les autres villes hôtes
de france toutes celles qui sont qui
peuvent être compliquées ou symboliques
ou voilà c'est vraiment prêter le bâton
pour se faire battre moi je trouve ça
extrêmement inconscient que de que de de
laisser faire c'est ce gouvernement en
se disant oui on voit moins de mots no
fly zone sous l'arc de triomphe un
gouvernement dit que la sécurité de ses
fans zone et assurez vous n'y croyez pas
ah ben excusez moi est ce que la voiture
là pendant la manif la manne les
manifestations des policiers est ce que
la sécurité était là est-ce que la
sécurité est là depuis des semaines où
on voit des des manifestations avec des
casseurs à l'intérieur s'ils font ce
qu'ils veulent comme ils veulent est ce
que la sécurité est là on est on est on
est en état d'urgence
le gouvernement n'est pas capable ou ne
veut pas appliquer les règles strictes
de l'état d'urgence est donc vraiment de
sécuriser tout mouvement de
manifestations ou de rassemblements tels
que pourraient être les fans zone de
l'euro donc oui il est sûr qu'à
préoccupations on a des exemples criants
qui ont lieu cette semaine
faut être idiot de ne pas comprendre ça
david douillet après l'euro la france
est candidate pour accueillir les jeux
olympiques de 2024 est-ce que selon vous
la menace terroriste qui pèse sur le
pays va empêcher paris d'être désignée
ville hôte
non la menace terroriste en réalité on
le voit de par les attentats qui sont
faits dans le monde entier
elle existe elle est là partout voilà on
a particulièrement ciblé ce qu'on a fait
en feront absolument ce qu'on a fait en
france
en revanche c'est de nous doter de tous
les outils pour compliquer la vie à ces
mêmes terroristes
en réalité ça veut dire quoi c'est comme
si vous avez vous que vous avez votre
maison avec votre porte d'entrée et vous
n'aviez qu'à v gros avant donc
évidemment le voleur mais peu de temps
pour rentrer chez vous là on en a mis
vingt 20 ans il met beaucoup de temps ça
qu'on de par les dispositions qu'on a
prise on va en complique grandement la
possibilité de mettre en place des
attentats dans notre pays mais si ils
veulent vraiment le faire ils peuvent le
faire n'importe où d'ailleurs
donc c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre
alors je veux pas jeter de l'huile sur
le feu auquel jusqu'à une psychose mais
c'est la vérité est la preuve puisque
bizarrement les derniers attentats ont
eu lieu en belgique
juste à côté de chez nous dans un
endroit où message compris les lois
n'avait pas encore évolué comme ici
alors à poursuivre le film de la semaine
puisque l'assemblée nationale a discuté
d'un projet de loi qui vise à simplifier
et moderniser la justice
les députés ont notamment supprimer les
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs un
dispositif créé par nicolas sarkozy en
2011 pour juger les mineurs récidivistes
de plus de 16 ans david douillet ces
tribunaux ne traiter que 1% des
contentieux c'est un constat
c'est un constat d'échec c'était
nécessaire de les réformer quand on a un
dispositif au départ qui qui part sur un
un bond qui est un bon principe les
tribunaux robert est un bon principe au
départ des multirécidivistes on le
reconnaît
moi j'habite à côté des mureaux voilà
jusqu'en et d'analyser la question d'un
vivier il faut se poser les tisseurs se
remettre en question mais de là à tous
supprimés et a touché non vous êtes
contre moi je sais je suis pour une une
autre appréciation pour remettre des
enfants dans le chemin de la vie parce
que c'est ça dont il s'agit
or et comment comment comment enfin il
ya des choses formidables
d'ailleurs qui auraient pu être mises en
place en leur donnant le choix ou la
possibilité de commuer leur première
peine sur d'autres dispositifs notamment
encadrés pourquoi pas et à l'époque
j'avais imaginé ce dispositif mais il ya
très longtemps j'ai encore je venais de
finir ma canne athlètes sur le bataillon
de joinville savez quand le service
militaire a été supprimé le bataan joy
qui accueillait tous les athlètes de
haut niveau s'est retrouvé sans sans
objectif sans objet bon le matin j'avais
il y avait toutes les installations
sportives
oui dès lors ce militaire tous les
athlètes de niveau faisait alors sur les
militaires là pour pas perdre de temps
et continuer à être performants bon on
en faisait une école de la seconde
chance à travers le sport
encadrés par des militaires voyez
on propose un enfant et il aurait pu
décider de ne pas le faire mais en tout
cas de commuer sa peine de prison sa
première peine de prison en
apprentissage d'un métier à travers le
sport mais aussi dans un environnement
sain et et et en leur établissement dans
je me couche tôt je me lève tôt je mange
sainement je fais du sport je m'occupe
de mon corps et puis j'apprends des
choses et en le formant aux métiers du
sport c'est formidable non si que bon
c'est des initiatives comme ça on en a
besoin je suis trop long ce sera un peu
un peu bon je suis pas sûr on va
terminer avec l'actualité d'hier puisque
depuis hier un david douillet
l'assemblée nationale compte un groupe
ii - les écologistes réformiste en et
par françois de rugy ont décidé de
rallier le groupe socialiste entraînant
de facto la disparition du groupe
écologiste qui ne comptent plus assez de
membres pour exister à strip de vilaine
tout avait pourtant si bien commencé
juin 2012 pour la première fois de leur
histoire les écologistes parviennent à
former un groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale
grâce à un accord avec le parti
socialiste la majorité fonctionne deux
ministres écolo sont même au
gouvernement
mais deux ans plus tard cécile duflot
n'accepte pas la nomination de manuel
valls à matignon elle claque la porte du
gouvernement et fait son grand retour à
l'assemblée nationale
travailler deux tendances cohabitent
alors au sein d'un même groupe
parlementaire ce qui reste fidèle à la
ligne gouvernementale et ceux qui se
placent dans l'opposition les divisions
devienne intenable
ils ont le droit de dire ce qu'ils
veulent par contre nous on n'a pas être
comptable des expressions de cécile
duflot de noël mamère on peut importe
octobre 2015 de nombreux cadres
historiques d'europe écologie les verts
quittent le parti pour créer leur propre
mouvement légitime à la ligne de
françois hollande proposons une écologie
positive illogique de propositions il
propose in écologique d'actes ou de
réalité
le groupe est au bord de l'implosion
pour le sauver
françois de rugy cède sa place à cécile
duflot le groupe assume alors de ligne
politique
il peut y avoir des nuances sur la
manière d'exprimer cette réponse y
compris sur les questions tactiques mais
ça c'est pas nouveau et ça ne va pas
changer deux présidentes deux réunions
de groupe
deux positions sur les grands textes de
loi malgré les divisions
le groupe survie par intérêt au dire est
ce parce que il y en existe pas
l'assemblée nationale si on appartient
pas un groupe pour la rép
ne serait ce que pour accomplir du
travail parlementaire on survit dans ce
dans ce groupe divisé qui ne sert qu'à
une chose nous permettre de travailler
février 2016 françois hollande acte la
rupture en nommant trois écologistes de
premier choix au gouvernement
barbara pompili coprésidente du groupe à
l'assemblée jean vincent placé président
de l'ue des oeufs et la propre
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts
emmanuelle cosse des nominations
stratégiques qui aggrave encore un peu
plus la fracture entre les deux lignes
ces dernières semaines la sphère
beaupain achève le groupe à l'assemblée
les négociations pour son remplacement
au poste de vice président est mal
tourné la situation politique pleine de
rancoeur personnelle ne pouvait plus
durer
david douillet cette explosion du groupe
et écologistes est ce que c'est
l'illustration de la volonté françois
hollande d'éliminer toute concurrence à
gauche
ouais c'est une belle stratégie - vous
moi je dis chapeau
oui bravo oui bah oui là il il avait
démarré on l'a on le sentait bien on le
voyait en son père
ça transpirait dès le début du
quinquennat et ses attaches à tout ça et
dès qu'il a pu en sortir pour les nommer
leur proposer des postes où était passé
avant et voilà le truc à le ce parti a
explosé complètement littéralement on
l'avait aussi à l'échelle de l'île de
france avec et pâquerette toute façon le
les socialistes et les écologistes et
lui les vinaigres cette région n'a pas
pu être gérée correctement pour ces
raisons le jean paul huchon à l'époque a
été prise au piège dans un état terrible
et malmené par le groupe écologiste qui
vient faire dans beaucoup de domaines à
peu près n'importe quoi voilà c'est une
catastrophe
le ski est terrible dans cette
affaire-là c'est que pour des raisons
politiques l'écologie la vraie écologie
qui est ni de droite ni gauche en pâtit
en fait alors c'est l'heure maintenant
de parler de revenir à l'actualité
briques de votre parti tout de suite la
loupe du scan
c'est à vous bonjour david douillet
bonjour excusez moi là d'un problème
technique
ça me permet de poser la première
question sur nicolas sarkozy hier soir
dès les soutiens les membres de
l'association de soutien à l'action
nicolas sarkozy ont reçu un mail de
votre part david douillet qui commence
ainsi je continue à me battre pour la
france et c'est pour cela que j'ai
choisi de m'engager au côté de nicolas
sarkozy rejoignez nous est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il ya une accélération dans
le mouvement qui va vers la candidature
j'espère vivre de nicholas artistique
mais il faut qu'il soit il faut regarder
on est bien oui on est on est presque
pas timoré remet le démarrage de la
primaire le dépôt des contraintes de la
candidature le nombre de parlementaires
de signature les deux miss à 9 septembre
début septembre il ya l'été qui au
milieu de tout ça il faut déjà parce que
moi je vais l'appeler à se présenter dès
aujourd'hui ah mais oui des mets fin le
plus rapidement possible parce qu'on en
a besoin
moi j'ai vu trop grand dans l'arène
rapidement est rapidement avant l'été
j'espère j'espère maintenant vous
le monde révèle dit il à je lui et dani
respectifs à sa twingo et comme je
l'avais dit en 2012 qui et pour qui
démarre un peu plutôt branché 70 à
l'époque selon vous je le pense oui il
faut pas reproduire cetera exactement
d'accord alors s'il n'est pas encore
candidat il nicolas sarkozy ne se prive
pas pour autant de de cibler ses
adversaires ses futurs adversaires à la
primaire que dit ti par exemple sur sur
juppé on peut tout dire mais pas qu'il a
du talent qu'est ce qui dit sur fion il
n'a pas d'idées pas d'originalité
est-ce que l' attaque frontale c'est la
bonne stratégie d'abord et là je me suis
toujours étonné de sémou de ses phrases
qui reviennent comme ça qui surgissent
de nulle part qui sont peut-être sorti
d'un contexte il l'a dit dans l'avion de
dans le retour de l'avion de new delhi à
une journaliste du point qu'il a acquis
la retranscription
moi je suis toujours méfiante c'était
ses affaires et bohème été victime de
phrases sorties de contexte soit dans un
livre ou autre chose je suis toujours
méfiant tout ce que je sais c'est ce que
j'ai vécu au sein d'un gouvernement avec
lui et y compris avec alain juppé
lorsque je suis rentré au ministère des
affaires étrangères comme secrétaire
d'état on a là des hommes de grande
qualité
voilà je vous le dis on a cette chance
c'est quand même incroyable tant mieux
des hommes d'état donc voila moi je
considère que c'est un film attention
qui s'installent autour de nos mauvais
que ça ça c'est ça c'est des vues c'est
un climat qui n'est pas négatif c'est ça
je veux vous faire comprendre
concurrentiel mais la négative
c'est sain c'est normal c'est de la
concurrence et c'est normal et de ses
concurrents et c'est moi le seul
avantage que je peux j'espère tirer
enfin que pour notre groupe de cette
primaire c'est qui est une émulation des
idées des talents voilà parce qu'ils ont
tous du talent et et si la raison pour
laquelle je suis nicolas sarkozy sait
que ce talent il nous l'a déjà montré
est que ce talent là
la première chose à mon sens ce qui
devrait faire c'est que on en aura
besoin grandement de son poids de son
envergure politique à l'échelle de
l'europe non parce qu'il faut d'abord
régler ce problème de l'europe avant de
s'attacher à nos problèmes nationaux
autre phrase rapportée de nicolas
sarkozy toujours dans le point ce
monsieur trump donc donald trump le
candidat républicain
l'élection américaine est réussie parce
qu'il ne se refuse aucune outrance assez
nicolas 4 sarkozy t-il dit est-ce que ce
ça peut être un modèle noir nicolas
sarkzoy sûr que l'on mon n'est pas aux
états unis vous verrez c'est enfin je
pense qu'il ne sera pas élu ce que trame
va changer complètement d'attitude il va
plus être aussi provocateur il va
rentrer dans le rang il va flatter les
gens qui sont très conservateur et très
frileux et vous verrez que il arrêtera
d'être dans un populisme exacerbé
d'alary science lors d'une récente
visite dans l'euro nicolas sarkozy a
indiqué que laurent wauquiez ferait
probablement l'intérim
lorsqu'il sera candidat à la primaire
l'intérim à la présidence du parti
est ce que il est suffisamment
rassembleur pour cela dans une période
où justement le râble partir a besoin de
se réunir
c'est la partie moi je remercie nicolas
sarkozy et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles je le suis d'avoir su refaire
un parti on est reparti de zéro en
réalité après le cataclysme copé fillon
il a reconstruit
il a rassemblé les gens ils à
désendetter un parti il a remis un
projet en route un projet d'opposition
en route bref il a fait le job ou quoi
et c'est juste formidable laurent
wauquiez il peut qu'il peut continuer ce
job là il savait qu'en arrivant quand
même au sein du parti a beaucoup en
général chacun a du caractère et sera
mieux parce que nous arrivons à vous
servir
j'ai deux secondes en général c'est
quand les voix sont tracés quand on a
posé les les les lignes de la ligne de
chemin de fer
quand on met le train dessus nicolas
sarkozy a construit la ligne des
républicains et et laurent ne sera que
la locomotive continuera à voler dans
mon sens c'est noté merci beaucoup merci
merci david douillet d'avoir fait la
semaine avec nos fonds et rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition de parlement hebdo